capture proof is changing the face of
mobile health and we're revolutionizing
the way patients and doctors communicate
if you're trying to describe a rash it's
easier to show a picture or if you have
a child doing some strange movements
it's easier to share a video we've had
doctors tell us that having the ability
to see a photo of a wound they're able
to keep a patient out of the emergency
room fifty percent of the time a year
ago capture proof started just in the
neurology market and since then we've
expanded to orthopedic surgery
dermatology plastic surgery and most
recently cardiology the one thing that
kept me up at night forever was being
fearful about our security if doctors
store patient photos on their phone and
it's not secure it can be a
fifty-thousand-dollar fine / photo we
can be a functional app and create a
functional app but if we are not secure
it doesn't matter capture proof has made
it so that our data is encrypted on the
go there's two factor authentication
necessary to sign into the site at all
times and no data is ever stored on the
phone or device itself capture proof
just received an innovation award from
the American Heart Association and two
of the top managed care organizations in
the US are now paying customers I
believe capture proof will be a name in
every household the ability to take two
photos and share them with your doctor
will have a positive impact worldwide